speaking of some of the worst human
beings on the earth we have this story
about Al Gore Fox News says Al Gore
mocked as a clown for Davos rant on rain
bombs boiling oceans and apocalyptic
preacher Jimmy filot reacts to Gore's
climate warnings on Fox and Friends so
you guys see this uh when I mean you
know Al Gore basically goes off saying
that like he like it was a really
unhinged rant I mean bro look I
criticized Alex Jones a while a while
several years ago because he went on I I
it was it was an old thing I remember
seeing him on on C-Span or something and
they were like ah it's Alex Jones and
then he immediately just turned to the
camera and goes paper wasn't they're
coming for you and I'm like but I'm like
when I show that to my mom they
immediately just be like this guy's nuts
it's like so you got to take the
opportunity and approach people on their
own terms on his own show I I think he's
great when he when he goes off
Al Gore
wanting to to warn people of a billion
climate refugees going the world's gonna
end it's gonna be raining bombs the oil
the oceans are going to boil and our
homes are going to sink I'm like okay
they they the crazy man you know calm
down and go to sleep yes talk he's
talking what he says is if there's a
billion migrants all of a sudden that
chaos will ensue and he's right but what
he's saying is that there will be a
billion migrants so that's the thing
where like I mean what's the evidence Al
you said 20 years ago that what the
world was ending intent like but that we
had 10 years cops are going to be
melting by yeah and they should be
because we're exiting congratulations
declines actually gone up since he made
these predictions we're we're still in
an ice age according to I think it's
Utah State people because of the the
flood 13 000 years ago 12 000 when the
meteors impacted North America and this
giant Global flood it it looks like
we're not in a nice age because the ice
melted but we're still in the Ice Age
just having this preliminary amount of
it melted it's all going to melt it's
supposed to that's why the Earth is
pouring iron into itself through the
river of blood in Antarctica it's
getting ready to fertilize for all this
new fresh water that's coming into it
and we're pulling carbon out of the air
dude we got the graphene Revolution on
the horizon this weird I was like
shaking about too much horse poop on the
ground and there are a lot of solutions
to a lot of the larger ecological and
pollution problems that the world is
dealing with except for the real
solutions are just being pushed away no
one's really talking about those issues
but when it comes to taxing people
regulating people controlling their life
micromanaging every aspect of them
putting them in little eco-friendly
sustainable neighborhoods that you can't
leave and you can only walk and bike
around 15 minutes anywhere in One
Direction when it comes to that yeah
they love that and when it comes to Al
Gore he said in 2009 that the North Pole
would be ice free in the summer of 2013.
I don't thing that happened there buddy
I I I think you were a little bit wrong
this guy's enough Drifter this guy's a
shill and it's important to note here he
made 330 million dollars off of his
green investment firm ever since losing
to George W bush there's a lot of money
in this grift there's a lot of money in
fear-mongering and he knows this grift
is being exposed so he has to step it up
he has to make this emotional trauma
this larger psyop as crazy as they can
so then Deutsche Bank of America that
we're at Davos they were also talking at
the same time during this conference
about you know we need we need to do all
of our business based on carbon
emissions we need to have we need to
reboot capitalism we need a social
credit score based on carbon we need to
make sure everyone is reporting their
own personal carbon this is nothing to
do with the environment this is
everything to do with the subjugation of
the human race and it's not in its plain
as day big money big interest big Power
trying to control you sorry Tim you had
something to say Oh I thought I was
going to say that what the left will
come out and do is they'll say no no no
Al Gore was right 20 years ago when he
said it would be you know ice free by
2013. but then we took action on climate
change and it stopped it from happening
that actually proves algar was right the
whole time yeah I mean I just would like
to shout out do not I do not know this
person at all but a book if you have a
child that you want to make aware of the
climate scam which you are absolutely
excited about about the subjugation of
humanity such an easy book very short
read it's called Uh inconvenient facts
and it's written by Gregory Whitestone
and it will wake you to the fact that
the ipcc is just a corrupt industry
every single model they ever have put
out is wrong and they rely on people not
understanding just how old the Earth is
and that it goes through coldness I mean
there was a medieval warming period
followed by a freeze I mean there's just
they're trying to actually make you
think that weather is something to be
fearful of and that these things don't
naturally happen like forest fires they
just naturally happen they've always
happened to the beginning of time things
get hot I just came back from South
Africa while we were there just
temperature hits in Africa the bush
Burns and it's a good thing that it
burns and so people they rely on the
ignorance of people that are widely
emotional which is why they start this
sort of brainwash when you are in high
school when you are in middle school if
there's always a different scare and
they've been wrong every time so if you
still believe that there are some
element of truth to this just go talk to
people in different generations and tell
them what their big scare was I was
generation global warming we still had
to watch a sad movie of polar bears
drowning and we're told that there were
going to be no polar bears left in fact
polar population has gone up since
inconvenient facts generation before us
they were told the exact opposite that
it was going to be global cooling they
were all going to freeze to death and
then they were like oh got that one
wrong so we're going to change it to
global warming there was the ozone layer
the whole remember the hole in the ozone
lay we're all going to die and then oops
which states that didn't happen there
was acid rain scare where kids were
taught that the oceans were going to
become so acidic and it was going to
rain from the sky and now it looks like
guys it's promising we're moving on to
rain bombs bundle up and buy a good
umbrella I'm gonna start selling
umbrellas to be fair on the on the ozone
thing we literally did ban the the CFCs
or whatever yeah so those the ozone
thing fluorocarbons yeah that was one
thing was like Hey if we keep using
these what is like
yeah that's a Nuance argument to
understand that but they've been trying
to use this kind of fear modeling
environmental drifts yeah and it's all
about saying some policies we need the
Paris Accord agreement what we need to
fix these things if you're really scared
is more of your money yeah I was going
to say Candace but but you don't
understand if if we give the government
more money the weather will be gooder
yeah that's the basic principle that
they work on because there are actual
things that we should address when it
comes to this climate when it comes to
our environment when it comes to
pollution especially when it comes from
uh the developing World especially when
it comes from China dumping all of the
plastic that Canada shipped to them
there's also a lot of waste a lot of
Destruction because of war and there's
so much hypocrisy at the world economic
Forum not not just them flying on their
private jets with record emissions
record number of jets uh estimated a
thousand one hundred jets flying in
there but but these are the same
individuals that almost in the same
breath are like we need to make sure
that there's not a peace deal with
Ukraine in Russia that's what the U.N
secretary said at Davos this year and in
the same breath they're like but we need
to make sure their environment's good
one of the biggest polluters is of
course the military-industrial complex
and they're cheering it on they're
calling for more war they're trying to
deny every kind of peace deal they're
trying to prolong it and this is the the
worst thing that you could possibly be
yes because they need more money exactly
they need the grip to keep going without
money everything is always about money
and it's the same people destroying the
environment that are coming to you
saying just give us more money and we'll
fix the environment in reality those
Solutions do not work and create more
problems and they fly private when they
talk about it it's very important on
your private jet to discuss Ukraine and
also climate and everything does it make
sense when it's put together it doesn't
matter because don't pay attention
because you're supposed to be ignorant
not realize that literally all they want
is money launch a new war and ruin the
climate at the same time they're telling
you that you've got to give them more
money so they can save the climate I
mean it's stunning to me and people that
get behind this initiatives over and
over and over again if you're really
trying to discern what big con is go
find the people that back the military
industrial complex go go find the people
that put a little Ukraine flag and told
you that this was your duty to go out
and defend Ukraine to ask no questions
about president zielinski who shut down
that speech I find that to be absolutely
ridiculous I Gotta Give a shot of DC
Drano who called Kevin McCarthy kievan
you Carthage
like a pin yeah like a yeah like there's
a pin and a flag another country's flag
I mean I that to me if you want a marker
of what real big con is go find out who
supports Ukraine and to this day is
still back in Ukraine from day one I was
like this is so obviously military
industrial complex this makes no sense
we know it's a corrupt country we know
that it washes laundry don't believe me
take it from The New York Times and
Washington Post five years ago and they
highlighted all of his ties to oligarchs
we installed the new government and we
intentionally went to war because they
launder our money and of course Hunter
Biden and President we hopped in
Afghanistan to get everybody home takes
one breath tomorrow we're going to be in
Ukraine I mean it's such obvious
foolishness at this point and that there
are people that are in our movement
pretending that they're whether America
first or they care about you know what's
happening to this country and then they
they support Ukraine like goodbye dude
goodbye how do you support this yeah and
then there's FTX right that was working
with with the world economic Forum yeah
that was working with the bank of
Ukraine that was laundering money not
only to of course a high-level Democrats
but also Republicans all those
politicians right now give back the
people's money I don't understand why
our justice system is not intervening in
the FTX Scandal and saying hey hey Mr
Biden or or Mr uh Crenshaw or miss or
whoever you got this money this money
was actually stolen from clients let's
make sure we give it back why can't we
have that conversation
I don't know if Crenshaw actually got
the money I'm just naming a politician
here so I don't know if it's Liz Cheney
I don't know who it is but there was a
fair amount of money mostly given to
Democrats some to Republicans as well
whoever got that money it was all
through shadowy secret kind of black
money that was given through different
packs and different organizations in
order to kind of launder it specifically
or but but there should be a national
conversation right now being like hey
people were robbed let's give their
money money back right now that money is
in the hands of corrupted politicians
right now that we're doing the bidding
of corrupted organizations like FTX that
the world economic Forum endorsed and
then deleted their endorsement of and
tried to hit it away from the internet
as they were promoting this larger Ponzi
scam that stole people's money which is
absolutely insane I would Advocate
letting Sam Beckman free Go free if he
can pay back the 10 billion and I know
he can he let him go free they'll kill
him he's even following how many crypto
billionaires or he's a drugged up puppy
yeah it's just insane I mean it's insane
they're dropping like flies I covered it
on my show I mean the mysterious death
of all these crypto billiona
millionaires what about that guy who who
tweeted like they're they're running an
entire money laundering thing in Puerto
Rico right off of that point Island 2.0
it's a pedophile ring blah blah blah and
he said they're going to kill me
four hours later found in the ocean with
full clothes on in his wallet guess he
just went for a swim and ended up with a
bullet in the back of his head exactly
like literally within four hours death
by Suicide I covered it all on my show
and he little said they're gonna kill me
it's always the same they just it's a
mysterious drowning and it's in Puerto
Rico he was in the Caribbean when this
happened four hours later after his last
tweet he was dead and he's one of five I
think five or six hundred billionaires
that have died in the last two years
under these unbelievably mysterious
circumstances I mean if you haven't
listened to that episode of my show just
to kind of shout myself out it's
actually the most popular episode that
I've that I've released recently it's
called um the mysterious death of crypto
billionaires it's insane it's insane and
no that is what we should be talking
about there's exactly very dangerous
going on and to your credit way more
important than anything we're talking
about with Stephen Crowder
um but that is I mean it's
it's around the world it's everywhere
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time